among Karl Marx's early works we find a
piece called estranged or sometimes
alienated labor depending on how you
want to translate the German turn and
friend of which we'll talk about in just
a moment and this is a very useful piece
for introducing students to to reading
Marx into thinking about Marx's ideas in
part because it doesn't have some of the
later baggage that's going to come with
his other writings and imperfect is what
you can see him doing here in a very
condensed form is talking about what
modern industrial capitalist society
does to people and he's talking about it
in ways that I think that many of us can
relate to at least in part so he's going
to discuss several different things in
this piece and we will hit on a few
other aspects besides this but one of
the most important parts of this is his
discussion of four modes of alienation
so we should think about this term
alienation or again in German and friend
um and what it means so to become
alienated means to become others for
some sort of relationship to break apart
or break down for an antagonism to arise
these are all ways of thinking about
alienation Marx is going to think about
it particularly in terms of what was
originally oneself becoming something
that is no longer oneself that that is
standing over against oneself so it's
kind of a a splitting that's going on
within the human being or in the
products of the human being or in
relations between human beings and I've
got some stuff here that we're gonna
we're going to play with in a moment and
we're going to look at each of these
four kinds of alienation and turn he is
going to turn out a kind of progression
so we're going to start with alienation
of the person from the product of labor
and that leads into alienation of the
person from the very active
of work that leads into this kind of
tricky passage that actually you know
the terminology is kind of kind of
difficult if you're not used to some of
the philosophical assumptions going on
but the basic idea is very easy to
understand relate to the person from
their species being and then finally we
get to the alienation of persons from
other persons and Marx says that it
works this way we don't actually begin
in a state of antagonism as many other
social theorists have have assumed and
so this is a good place to start going
into the manuscript itself he's
criticizing what he calls political
economy and what we understand today by
by sort of a mixture of political theory
and economic theory would be what he's
calling political economy at the time or
policymaking is another another term for
it and one of the basic assumptions that
was being made by much of the political
economy that he's dealing with like for
example M Smith is that you have these
these free individual agents who relate
to each other by producing and and
trading their property with each other
and this makes sense
actually for certain kinds of society
Marx talks about handicraft work and you
know what goes into labor and what the
person receives from it but this
actually doesn't this doesn't replicate
the way things really work in much of
ancient society or medieval society and
it certainly doesn't doesn't answer to
what's going on in modern society it's
kind of a smokescreen
now Marx doesn't say you know well it's
it's just to be thrown away he says
there's some ideas here that really
matter like for example private property
they begin from the assumption of
private property they don't analyze it
further what we want to do mark says is
think about well where does private
property actually come from how does it
come into existence how does it come
into being so political economy the
problem with that is that they're
they're assuming things rather than
actually examining and analyzing them
and so that the explanations that they
give every other circular or they're
rather superficial they don't get it the
real heart of the matter and what is
Mark's keen to understand the condition
of human beings in modern capitalist
societies so what we need to do then he
says is we need to instead of going back
to some sort of primitive condition or
some abstract doctrine we need to
proceed from what he calls an actual
economic fact we need to begin with
something that actually happens here's
the fact that he begins from the worker
becomes all the poor the more wealth he
produces the more is production
increases in power and size and that
sounds a little paradoxical doesn't it
if somebody's producing a lot of value
shouldn't they be getting paid more well
you know that's not the way things often
do work many of you watching this I'm
sure have worked wage jobs where the
more that you produce you don't actually
get paid more you get paid by the hour
for what you do
or you get paid a salary for a given
amount and if you go beyond that you
know there could be bonuses or
incentives but you're certainly not
getting the lion's share of the value
that that you're producing for somebody
else for perhaps an institution or
perhaps an owner or stockholders so why
does the worker then become poorer the
more wealthy producers because he's
producing value that he doesn't partake
in so it means that relative to that
value that's that's out there he or she
has lots of it and the more that they do
this the more that workers in the plural
do this the more the process turns
against them according to Marx so he
says the worker becomes an ever cheaper
commodity the more commodities he
creates the devaluation of the world of
men is in direct proportion to the
increase
using the value out of the world of
things this is a very interesting idea
and this goes back to the when I got up
here the basic process that's going on
through production is that you've got
somebody who's a worker and that person
is expanding labor which is coming from
themselves it's their own energies it's
their own attentiveness it's their own
you know focus and choices of what to do
even if you're working at a what seems
to be totally routine job where you feel
like you're just you know stamping
widgets on an assembly line you are
investing something of yourself in that
activity and what comes about is some
sort of object a product now in many
cases when a person produces something
think for example of cases where you're
not producing something for sale but
you're producing something for your own
use if for example you enjoy cooking and
your spouse or boyfriend or girlfriend
comes home and you've made a wonderful
meal that you're going to enjoy it
together and you've even done things
like you know put on the romantic music
and the candle lights and tablecloth and
gone did a lot of you know a lot of work
for that that you've put something of
yourself onto that table no it's not
totally of yourself it's not like you
you know cut into yourself and cooked up
a steak of flash or something like that
that'd be kind of disgusting women but
what you've done is taken raw materials
and you've taken tools and you as the
creator have harnessed those things and
created something new and now you get to
sit down and enjoy it cuisine is an
interesting example because when a
product is created it's created
precisely in order to be destroyed by
being consumed
so even artworks that are culinary are
not meant to last
what if you build yourself a house
or you weave yourself a cloak or you
knit yourself a sweater a macrame or
whatever it is that people do with that
sort of thing
well you get to enjoy the product and
you get to say I made that you get to
see something of yourself in what it is
that you've done when you write a paper
for example if you're just sort of going
through the motions there's not that
much of yourself in the paper when you
really invest yourself in doing research
and synthesizing multiple points of view
and deciding which one you're going to
argue for and which one your are against
there's a lot of you in there Plato says
for you know for example in one of his
dialogues that people often treat the
things that they make as if they're
their own children because they see
something of themselves in there so the
laborer in certain conditions is able to
externalize themselves into the product
which then they can enjoy but in many
cases the product doesn't belong to the
laborer
the product in wage-labour in modern
industrial labour belongs to the one who
has provided the means of production the
one who has provided the conditions
under which it can be produced the
conditions of work as a matter of fact
even the labor of the person doesn't
belong to the person when they're being
hired but they're doing the same thing
of externalizing themself they're
creating something that stands over
against them
as an object and as they create more and
more they're giving more and more of
themselves to something else they're
putting more and more of themselves out
into the social world and there's less
and less of them there because it's
being taken away so Marx goes on and he
says Labor's product the object that
labor produces can
it is something alien as a power
independent of the producer so in a lot
of jobs when you've created something
that thing confronts you as something
independent of you the product of labor
is labor which has been embodied in an
object you are embodying your labor and
the object there you know what you're
making which has become material this is
something really distinctive about human
beings
I mean other animals do labor to a
certain extent you know ants build
anthills and they're pretty and you know
pretty impressive and bees make these
amazing you know lattice works of
honeycomb but we do much more than that
and as individuals we're able to see
ourselves and our products and we're
also able to see the loss of ourselves
in our products so he goes on and he
says Labour's realization is its
objectification that's what it means to
actually labor if you're laboring and
you don't produce any products you're
not actually laboring you're just
screwing around you're not actually
making anything you're maybe just having
some fun you might say well what about
the fun maybe that's a product well you
know that's that's not the same thing as
what Marx is talking about here the very
nature of Labor is to produce things
that stand against us as independent
independent existences now some of these
objects are some of these products might
be things like tools or they might be
things like raw materials or they might
be things like machines and these things
can go back into this whole process here
and feed into it so that the laborer is
relying upon those things but he's being
confronted or she's being confronted by
them they are the product of somebody
else's labor but they're not being
confronted by them as labor they're
being confronted by them as things
things that impose demands you know if
I'm working in a drill press you know
you got to be kind of careful with those
thinking years back when I was actually
in contact with those sorts of things I
don't know what they're like today maybe
they're totally computerized but you had
to be kind of careful with them you
could mess yourself up on those because
they you know they are something
independent of you you put your hand in
the drill cross you're not going to hand
because the drill press is not going to
think about should I do this or
shouldn't I do this but that drill press
is actually the consolidated the
consolidation of somebody else's labour
that drill press belonging to the
factory owner it is the product of not
the factory owners labour but some other
worker in some other plant so he says
the laborers the laborers realization
appears as loss of realization so the
worker realize losses realization losses
becoming you know what they're supposed
to be to the point of starving to death
the the industrial processes lead to
economic processes in the marketplace
that according to Marx are going to
depress wages lower and lower and lower
and lower so that the workers are
getting a smaller and smaller share of
the wealth that's being generated even
if there's like a net increase in the
amount of pay it could be that the
workers are getting less and less of a
share of the economic boon or production
and eventually it can get to the point
where they are just hanging up so he
says so much does objectification
appears loss of the object that the
worker is robbed of the objects most
necessary not only for his life but for
his work labor itself becomes an object
that could be bought and sold labor
itself becomes an object which he can
obtain only with the greatest effort in
the most irregular interruptions instead
of the labor being able to like come out
and say look I've got talent I've got
skills I've got energy just put me to
work the labor has to go to other people
and beg them to allow the laborer to
work on stuff to make product
for them this is what we call filling
out a job application going to
interviews I think many of you know what
that sort of thing is like and some of
the net promised us is that the labourer
is becoming alienated from the product
that he or she is is developing he says
the more that the worker by his labour
appropriate appropriates the external
world the more he deprives himself of
the means of life in two respects the
external world more and more ceases to
be an object belonging to his labour to
be his Labor's means of life second it
more and more ceases to be a means of
life in the immediate sense means for
the physical substance of the worker the
worker gets worse and worse off in
relation to the world of things so he
says the worker becomes a servant of the
object the object asserts itself over
against the worker the worker receives
work he doesn't just do work he has to
wait for somebody to say okay anyways he
receives a means of substance by this is
that mark says this enables them to
exist first as a workers second as a
physical subject and notice it's only as
a worker that he can maintain himself as
a physical subject and it's only as a
physical subject that he's a worker so
you know I mean this is something to
think about in the age of automation
where we're replacing a lot of people by
computers and by machines and robots
human beings require some sort of goods
in order to keep on surviving in a
industrial society like the one that we
live in you know taking aside you know
the welfare system or safety net or you
know if we ever end up having a
guaranteed basic income if you don't
work you're going to you're going to
starve you're going to die because you
won't get anything to to eat and the
worker or more and more has to fit him
or herself into the demands of the
object that is being created on the
objects that have been created so Marx
talks about this and into an interesting
way
Daisy says it's true that labor produces
for the rich wonderful things but for
the worker it produces privation doesn't
actually make the worker better off it
produces palaces but for the worker
hubble's it produces beauty but for the
worker deformity so that's one aspect of
the alienation here the person by
investing their labour is actually
losing something of himself in the
process and not getting anything back
marks have some really interesting
remarks about machines as well he says
it replaces labour by machines but
throws one section of the workers back
into barbarous types of labour and it
turns the other section into a machine
it produces intelligence but for the
worker stupidity [ __ ] ISM so you know
modern industrial work tends to require
two kinds of labor unskilled labor the
machine that can compensate for that you
just push the buttons and you stand
there pushing buttons all day you know
the jetsons is a great example of that
George Jetson was living in this you
know sort of utopian society where his
only job is to sit at his desk and one
hour a day push a button because that's
pretty much all he can do now that's not
developing human talent that's not
developing human capacities that's not
allowing anybody to do anything
interesting and that's kind of a jokey
one too because for a lot of people on
the skilled laborer means doing
back-breaking stuff that you know we
don't have machines to do quite yet
where the human beings are just a little
bit better at it than the current
existing machines the other possibility
is labour that skill but that becomes
more and more and more professionalized
that becomes more and more you know
routinized
and if it becomes less and less one
investing oneself and more just one
selling ones labor to it to get things
done so Marx goes on and he says the
relationship of the man of means to the
objects of production and production
itself is just a consequence of this
this first relationship
the direct relationship of labour to its
products is the relationship of the
worker to the objects of production so
we have alienation of the person from
what it is that they're producing the
first form of alienation
now the second form is stemming from
this and Marx will focus now on the she
says so what's the alienation of labor
the labor is external to the worker it
doesn't belong to his intrinsic nature
in his work he doesn't affirm himself
but denies himself he does not feel
content but unhappy he doesn't develop
freely his physical and mental energy
but mortify his body and ruins his month
so the activity of work when it's left
up to the person they will choose the
kind of work that they actually find
fulfilling and that doesn't mean that
they'll always do exactly the same thing
like they'll decide it you know when
they're 18 years old well I'm a musician
or I'm a Mason or I'm a carpet layer and
just do that because they may be they
may develop a they may grow and they may
decide I want to take some classes and
do something else maybe I'm going to
become a doctor maybe I'm going to learn
history and become a historian maybe
I'll learn how to code as new
opportunities become available people if
they're in a condition where they can
actually choose the kind of work that
they want to do they'll steer themselves
towards them and people do find work
fulfilling when it's the kind of work
that they actually freely choose now you
might say well people freely choose to
go and work you know at a fast-food
restaurant or in janitorial services or
jointly not to join the military or
whatever well you know there's there's
then there's free a lot of cases there's
not an awful lot of options yeah person
needs to be able to eat and sustain
themselves on sometimes their family so
they have to take what they can get a
lot of adjuncts for example or or in
that condition it's one thing to say
well if you don't like teaching for a
profession just go find yourself a full
time job teaching well if there's no
jobs you can't do that well don't go do
something else
well you know that's what you find
fulfilling you're probably not going to
find you know doing something else is
fulfilling so what happens is the
activity of work itself in industrial
society it's you can say dictate that
shows them or it's chosen only within
certain ranges you know if the mill is
the only real job in town other than
maybe working in the saloon or sweeping
floors you work at the mill whether
you're suited for that sort of thing or
not so this means that the labor becomes
as Mel says external not something that
they have a desire or a drive to do so
what's the the consequence of this the
worker feels himself outside only feels
himself outside his work and his work
his work feels outside himself work
becomes alienating in that case when we
talk about work being soul-crushing
that's that's you know an extreme form
of alienation when you dread it having
to get up in the morning and face the
commute to go into your workplace this
is exactly what Marx is talking about
right here the work becomes something
that you want to avoid now human beings
want to be themselves they want to
actually express themselves you know
when you can work in expressive ways
like thank god I've got this cuz I get
to actually do something I enjoy talk
about philosophy it's you know it's not
onerous work it is still a labor it does
take efforts but you enjoy it you put
yourself into it so it creates a kind of
divide between the realm of what I have
to do when I'm stuck doing what I have
to show up for 40 hours a week or you
know Marx's day many anymore hours yeah
and where the person finds themselves
and what's left for most people what
Marx calls animal functions eating and
drinking having sex trying to create the
conditions under which you can have sex
that that can often take a lot more time
than having sex he talks about you know
the equivalent of preening he his phrase
is actually where is it
drought swelling and dressing up you
know those are things actually that
animals do they they to some degree
decorate their nest they build you know
little things they putter around they
play those are all good things by the
way Marx is not knocking any of those
things but he's saying that when we
detach them from the world of work
we're losing what nowadays we call
work/life balance right some people will
like throw themselves entirely on this
side and the rest of their life you know
suffer is as a result some people can't
wait to get out of work because work
sucks for them and they're there they're
saying I can't you know I can't stand
being here soon as that that time clock
goes I'm out of here and don't bother me
over the weekend I don't want to hear
about it
matter of fact lotos people are hard to
get work out of at work so what happens
here is there's this splitting that
takes place and again human beings are
alienated from themselves they're unable
to be realized in
their workplace so he says these are you
know eating drinking procreating of
genuinely human functions but taken
abstractly separated from the sphere of
all other human activity internet is
soul and ultimate atoms they become just
animal functions we lose our nature as
human beings so you know when when
people would look down on the workers
and say yeah look at those people all
they do is get drunk and screw around
and you know gamble and you know
obviously they're only good for putting
in the mill or putting in the factory
Marx would say well that's because
you've been putting him in the factory
that's because you haven't given them
any work that they can actually take any
delight in any pride in that they can
identify themselves right so that's the
the second thing
now we get to one that's a little bit
more tricky or perhaps even a little
mystifying for some people reading us
for the first time but again you'll see
that this is not anything all that all
that hard to relate to he talks about us
as being species so you know what what
is the kind of species where the human
species we are humanity and each human
being is a member of humanity so I'll
pick that just by going like this each
individual is a little hurt of humanity
now what is definitive of humanity this
is where Mark starts getting very
metaphysical answers talking about the
natural world right inorganic nature
organic nature so this is an organic
nature business is everything that's
that's not living organic nature we make
use of primarily by eating you know we
eat other animals we eat plants if
you're vegetarian or vegan you know you
one of those but the rest of us both of
them and we take things from the natural
world to continue our our existence and
every animal does this and other animals
also take things from the inorganic
world so you know when bees are making
their honeycombs I'm not sure exactly
what it's made of but I'm willing to bet
that it's not all made of organic
material if they're getting it some of
it from somewhere else and they're there
relating to their environment so we
human beings do that as well but we do
that in a much more expansive way
because we are beings that are conscious
we relate to the rest of the natural
world through a consciousness and we
really are the consciousness of the
other natural world so Mars will talk
about the the natural world as being our
inorganic body so think of the human
being and there were the human species
as being in the world as being you know
what what in some ways makes the world
turn makes the world what it is this is
a humanistic human eccentric perspective
that Marx has how do we do that we do
them in part through theoretical
activities through through thinking
about the world but we do this mostly
through practical activity through
production through taking things from
the natural world and making them into
other things and we do this through free
choices through actions that we will
that is what it means to be human in
this sense to be of the essence of
humanity to to be part of the species
being that's what human being that's
what makes us human beings what does
modern industrial production do cuts us
off from them it turns our species being
as productive being into mere mean
to continue our individual existence we
take our capacity to do what's in Marx's
view the highest function of human
beings to do work productive activity to
take the the world and transform it and
we turn it into a way to make a buck so
that we can buy our groceries and pay
for our gas and make it from you know
from paycheck to paycheck to paycheck it
marks by the way he's not blaming the
people who who are stuck in that
situation he's blaming the people who
imposed that upon them and he's saying
what this does is it isolates us from
human being because human being over
here is seen as we're value resides
where
meaning resides you know sometimes
people talk about living the real life
that's over here if you're stuck working
all the time and working in a profession
where you don't make much you know and
you're getting your most of your Labor's
being appropriated for somebody else and
you're not valued you begin to think of
your life as not that meaningful and
other people as doing what it is to
really be human that's a profound form
of alienation to be alienated from what
Marx calls species being finally we get
to the fourth kind of alienation I'm not
going to put anything up on the board
because I don't actually need to we
really needed from other people the
workers don't exist in a kind of
solidarity with each other bye-bye you
know virtue of the fact that they work
together they actually have an
antagonistic relationship to each other
much of the time because you know if I
see myself as this alienated unhappy
being well that other poor sucker over
there is pretty much the same thing why
would I care about what happens to him
if people are dehumanized if people are
alienated detached from their labor
detached from productive activity
detached from the very meaning of the
species then
it's not very you know much of a stretch
to say they don't matter they matter
insofar as they get in my way and so
there's a lot of antagonism competition
entity that takes place but this is
happening because this alienation of
person from person seeing the other as
just another not as another self not as
being like me happens because of all of
this alienation here so if you could
find some way to eliminate this kind of
invitation that would affect this kind
of alienation that would become a thing
of the past
now Marcy has a few other things that he
thinks are important to think about in
in this manuscript and I'm not gonna
actually hit on all of them I just want
to hit on one there is a character that
we haven't really been talking about
throughout this whole thing so you know
if the worker and the products and work
has been alienated from the worker what
does it belong to this is the question
of private property
where did private property come from
well it came from expropriating the the
work the labor of the worker and it's
fruits the product so mark says you know
who is this actually
who is this benefiting who is taking
this he says let's see how this concept
of estranged alienated labor must
express and present itself in real life
if the product of labor is alien to me
if it's become other it's become foreign
if it confronts me as an alien power
then to who does it belong that's not
belonging to me
more if my very vitality my very energy
my creativity my everything that I put
into my work isn't really mine well then
whose is it so this is an interesting
question
maybe it's the gods and in primitive
societies this is an answer that people
often get according to Marx he says in
the earliest times the principal
production you know building of temples
appears to be the service of the gods
and the product belongs to the gods
leases the gods on the room were never
the Lords of labor no more was nature so
the gods were just a stand-in for
something else for other people well who
are these other people that well you
know we have to sort of do a process of
elimination it's not the worker it's not
the vast majority of the people that are
actually doing work and generating thing
it must be what we can call the elites
they're the ones right expropriating and
in modern society the elites are the
bourgeois the modern capitalist class
it's no longer the nobility or you know
the military class or any of those sorts
of things it becomes the bourgeois the
people who own the means of production
as he says you know it belongs to some
other man than the worker if the workers
activities of torment to him to another
must give satisfaction and pleasure and
he says notice here that a person's
relationship to themselves becomes
objective and actual through their
relationship to the other person so how
does the bourgeois see the the human
being this is where we can skip ahead he
has some really interesting things to
say about this I'm gonna skip over the
Equality of wages discussion on
towards the very end where he says and
these are just sort of reflections that
he doesn't follow up but he says
everything that appears in the worker is
an activity of alienation of
estrangement appears in the non worker
as a state of alienation an estrangement
so the bourgeois himself or herself is
not entirely you know
integrated with it they're in a state of
alienation this is an activity of
alienation the worker's real practical
attitude and production and to the
product appears the non worker
confronting him as a theoretical action
so practice and we have Theory over here
or you might say working and under
management that he says the non worker
does everything against the worker which
the worker does against himself but it
is not a - against himself what he does
against the worker what Marx is saying
here is that this process of alienation
involves the worker actually doing part
of this to themselves because the
bourgeois is inflicting this upon them
it has the conditions under which they
have to work so it becomes very
difficult to just say well don't be
alienated no because this becomes a
condition of being that is
self-replicating that not only a
self-replicating and the individual but
also in their culture among their fellow
employees among their you know family
among their their class among their
workers is where the alienation of
persons from other persons makes a big
difference here so we've seen the
various ways in which human beings are
alienated in industrial society it's
presented to be quite complex doesn't